[Music]
[Music]
here in this video we will look at 30
different monsters and 30 different ways
they will kill you okay so let's not
waste any time on introduction and
useless blabbering so subscribe if you
haven't already and now let's get to it
number one the xenomorph this is a
creature from the alien franchise and
the basic ones the drones will stab you
with their tail to kill and if not then
they'll make you a hose for face huggers
to lay their embryos in you and you'll
die because a young chest burster alien
will burst out from your body
number two rodan this monster here is a
titan from the monsterverse movie
godzilla king of the monsters
how it'll kill you well it will swallow
you whole along with your parachute if
you're a jet fighter pilot or like most
others you'll die in its hurricane-like
winds which it causes when it flies down
number three hellholk another monster
from the monsterverse but it's a hollow
earth creature from the movie godzilla
vs kong its way of killing you is it
will carry you off drop you down or rip
your limbs off with its beak either way
it's a gruesome death
number 4 leaf wings this is a small
creature from the movie gong skull
island of 2017.
just one isn't much of a threat but a
swarm will carry you off and rip you to
shreds mid air
number five anaconda this creature right
here is a giant snake from the movie
anaconda and anaconda the hunt for the
blood orchid if it finds you it will
constrict you squeeze all the air out of
you
crush your bones and swallow you whole
number six velociraptor this entry right
here is from the jurassic movies and it
is a human-sized dinosaur but it is
quite fast intelligent and deadly the
way it will kill you is either it will
stab your body with its oversized claw
or rip your guts open or twist and break
your neck
number seven carnictas a strange animal
from the movie king kong of 2005 you can
fight one off uh with a sword or a
machete but a group of these creatures
will immobilize your limbs by swallowing
them and then slowly rip them off
including your neck and head
number 8 smoke
it is not fair without a dragon on this
list so this dragon here is from the
hobbit movies
it's huge in size and it will either
swallow you whole if it's hungry or burn
you to a crips with its steering hot
flame if it's mad at you
number nine ghidorah okay so back to the
monster verse here we have the false
king king ghidorah this titan has been
seen to vaporize an entire platoon of
soldiers with its electrical gravity
beams and it can also swallow your hole
if it chooses to
number 10 white spikes another alien on
this list this one is from the 2021
movie the tomorrow war this alien
creature is a swarm species but even a
single one can beat you to death and
even shoot you with killing spikes from
its tail from a distance
number 11 medusa coming in from the
clash of the titans this greek monster
has the body of a beautiful woman but a
tale of a serpent and snakes for hair
that has eyes that can turn you into a
stone statue and then smash it to dust
number 12 the predator since we have an
entry from
xenomorphs we will also include the
predator as well this alien here is an
expert hunter it will hunt you down
shoot you with its plasma beams rip your
spine off of your body cut you with its
weapons etc pretty much kill you in
every possible way except eating you
13. arachne lobster this 50 foot tall
crustacean slash insect creature from
the movie the miss has a pair of
gigantic pencils that can cut your body
in half like scissors to a piece of
paper imagine being sliced in half by an
overgrown lobster
number 14 tentacles from planet x yet
another entry from the movie the myth
this creature is seen as a giant spiky
tentacle being with powerful suction
cups that curls around the victim and
consumes the prey alive as the tentacles
envelop it slowly and gradually
number 15 graboid this subterranean
creature from the movie tremors is a 30
feet long
worm-like creature and senses your every
footstep the way you'll die in meeting
this monster is that it will immobilize
you with its snake-like tongues and then
drag you underground and swallow you
number 16 the t-rex the mighty rexy and
her other tyrannosaurus specimens will
chase you down and chomp down on you
with this massive bite force that has
the force of over 10 000 pounds per
square inch you'll hear and feel every
bone break before you meet your maker
number 17 the blob it is an amorphous
mass of alien goo that appears in the
1958 film of the same name appearing as
a mass of red gelatin this creature
acting purely on instinct to feed will
envelop you with its constituent mars
and digest you alive
18. arachnids these are aliens from the
starship troopers movies
they've had quite a number of human
kills quite a number they will
decapitate your arms cut you in half
with their mouth pincers and also impale
you with their limbs
19. death angels another alien monster
from a quiet place
they are attracted to sound and will
kill anything that makes it its mode of
killing is by ramming a person at full
speed over the fast blunt blow from its
forelimbs
20. sarlacc this classic alien monster
was first seen in the jedi returns of
star wars and it is a desert ambush
predator and will swallow anything that
falls into its trap and digests anyone
slowly with his highly acidic stomach
juice digest anything except vascular
steel
21 mother long legs another strange
creature from kong skull island 2017
this creature stalks prey in the lush
bamboo forest of the island and if it
gets you it will definitely impale you
with its long limbs like shrimp kebab
22. dementors from the fantastic magical
world of harry potter we have these grim
reaper-like monsters that will surround
you and will slowly and gradually suck
your soul and life force out from your
body
23 symbiotes the venom symbiotes are in
general deadly beings that can transform
hoes into powerful entities a symbiote
with a hose will eat your head clean out
of your body while a symbiote by itself
will kill you by just bonding with you
since many won't be suitable to host it
number 24 the harvester queen this one
is a gigantic alien monster and has
advanced technology able to defend
itself with a force feel and kill anyone
by vaporizing them with this powerful
plasma gun it can also crush you with
his feet if it chooses to
number 25 trolls from the law of the
rings and the hobbit movies these troll
monsters will kill you by impaling you
with weapons or if you're unlucky enough
will capture you and roast you over a
hot fire and sprinkle some seasoning for
making you into a hearty dinner
26. sheila another middle-earth monster
that will have you for lunch this
gigantic spider monster will paralyze
you with a sting and wrap you up in the
tough silk that it makes from its own
body and then let its venom digest you
from within and will suck out all your
juice
27. indominus rex this is a hybrid
dinosaur from the movie jurassic world
it is hyper intelligent and very
sadistic it kills for sport and for a
human like you it will grab you with its
hand and bite just half of you and throw
the other half away
28 skull crawler this is a monster
versus species that is hyper carnivorous
and lives in a constant state of
starvation it will bite you in half or
swallow your whole depending on the size
of the specimen you're lucky to face
29. kong yet another titan from the most
of us in this list and it is the eighth
wonder of the world and just like any
other incarnation of the ape titan it
will kill you by stomping on you with
its foot or smash you into a pulp with
its fist
and 30. shin godzilla lastly we have the
king of the monsters as a hyper-evolving
monster it will kill you in many ways
with its hot flame like a dragon stump
on you like kong swipe you out with its
tail like a bat to a ball or just
vaporize you with its atomic breath
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam